number five do not let your children do
anything that makes you dislike them
this has sort of been a thin line to at
least the beginning part of our yeah
well the first thing is it's the monster
thing like the beauty of beasts thing
you are not a good guy and you will take
revenge on your children if they
misbehave you think oh no I like my
children it's like other people might
not like them maybe they don't behave
very well you know and you think you
like them because you're a saint but
you're not and you will take revenge on
those children if they do things that
make you dislike them so you're in the
grocery store and you've got a four year
old in the four year olds pretty smart
checking you out all the time
you're like hope I'm you and prodding
you even seeing what's there because
that's what little kids do they're not
that verbal so they're there they're
like they they have you could compare
their behavior in some ways to pack
animals like dogs which is why they like
dogs and get along with dogs they
understand each other you know and so
they're testing you out and so they have
a temper tantrum in the store and you
don't know what to do about it what you
do your kid has a temper tantrum in the
store you pick up the child you go
outside with them you stand them up
somewhere and just let them have it let
them have the temper tantrum it's like
they'll get sick of it soon enough go
somewhere boring and dull say well have
a doorman then the kids done you say
we're gonna stand right here till you
decide that you're gonna behave the
child knows what that means it's like
you're gonna behave or we're just gonna
stand here it's like fine okay you don't
do that the child has a temper tantrum
it's the third one you know you're
embarrassed you're turning red
everyone's sweating everyone's looking
at you like you're a horrible parent
it's like really unpleasant think oh I
love my child I like my child it's like
no you don't that's a lie you go home
the kids forgotten all about it you know
they go in their room they make a little
drawing they're all thrilled they come
out and show it to you and maybe they
did a really good job you know maybe
they're even a little guilty about
having the damn tantrum but you man
you're not happy and you think yeah
that's nice and you go back to whatever
useless thing you're doing and you think
I got that little bastard and you think
no I wouldn't think that it's like yet
wrong you would wrong
normally would you think it you would
act it out and if you don't think that
that's true then you don't know yourself
very well and so you got to think that
little kid is little and powerless well
notice powerless as you might think but
fundamentally you got the upper hand and
you've got the proclivity for tyranny
deeply rooted in you and so you better
be real careful around that child I used
to tell my kids you know when I was not
in a good mood say like it would be
better if you were in your room and they
didn't mind they knew what it meant you
know they were very young they could
understand that it's like I look you're
a fine kid you know pat pat pat I'm not
any good mood things are likely to be
unpleasant why don't you just go play in
your room for a while Slyke way they
went they knew how to play in their room
you know cuz I didn't want them being
around me when I wasn't being gonna be a
good guy yeah and so in kids they they
know they can handle that man they can't
handle lies they can handle that sort of
truth no problem and so like I both my
wife and I we were very careful it's
like when we're starting to not be happy
with the kids with one kid or the other
it was time to have a chat and figure
out what it was that had gone off the
rails and how we were gonna fix it so
that we were like thrilled to have that
kid around and that's the thing about
Kansas you can be thrilled to have them
around not always you're tired you're
hungover like you've had a bad day the
kids cranky like I'm not saying this is
utopia it's not that's not the point
but the point is though you you can
manage your relationship with your kids
and you can have an honest relationship
with them and then it will be the best
relationship with anybody you've ever
had in your life